Mike was seeing one of my oldest friends
at comedy and we just we just looked at
an article here it says I'm dating a 23
year old woman who looks like an
eight-year-old I'm not a creep yeah
nobody thought that show this article
sometimes old To Catch a Predator Clips
will come up on my Tick Tock yeah and
it's really funny I mean you like you
forget that how Wild that show was it
was so fun but they all thought they
were like gonna get to go home
afterwards yeah well they thought it was
like a warning yeah yeah like they were
like I get it yeah no you're right I'm
sorry no I won't I won't tell an
eight-year-old boy I want to suck his
[__] ever again I'm wrong here yeah uh
never happened again thank you yeah now
this guy's dating he's he's 23 and he's
date wait the woman's 23 yeah but she
looks eight it's not really a story I
mean what's the big deal yeah she looks
like this
she literally looks like she looks like
a ventriloquist yeah she's uh and TLC of
course has done a show about her because
why wouldn't TLC and her name is Shawna
Ray
and there's something wrong with her uh
clearly
um
people don't understand that I am an
adult she's from Long Island she's from
Long Island
um
if it's uh the second season answer oh
yeah the second season of the show
premieres uh and follows Rey as she
looks for love and considers whether she
wants to pursue a college degree looks
for love so it's just it this is To
Catch a Predator yeah now the show is
called my eight-year-old girlfriend yeah
my eight-year-old surprise my child
I mean this is not can you imagine if
you brought her
she does look like a child can you
imagine if you brought her to your
parents and you said this is my
girlfriend Shawna Ray yeah
if you look at me you see an
eight-year-old she told the post but if
you took the time to look at the details
in my face my hands are maturity my body
if you take the time to actually talk to
me you really understand that I'm a 20.
I'll tell you what I have tits and my
[__] gets wet
okay what is the dude like what's his
story she's kind of attractive though
she's not badly yeah I mean what's the
problem here I mean uh
well look at this photo
look at that photo
it's just the way she's dressing she's
got to dress a little older I mean he's
a pedophile yeah there's you know right
yeah but that's the best way to be a
pedophile don't you think it's the best
he look at him look how happy he is yeah
yeah he found it
like look how thrilled he is he's like
wait a minute what he's like God
she's like I have this condition I'm
actually 23 he's like yeah thank you
Jesus the chat room he goes guys I found
a 23 year old she looks like she's eight
and you guys like man I just I just
molest kids in my neighborhood yeah he's
like riding he goes listen guys the
thing that we all want does exist yeah
yeah you can have your cake and eat it
too yeah I do a bit about how like the
day you realize that you're not a
pedophile that's a great day in your
life right you know
this is it's it's weird to see yeah and
uh it's unfortunate
that but she deserves probably gets
carted a lot I guess recorded she's not
allowed in the thing they'll go there's
a fake ID she'll go it's a government
issued ID they'll go get the [__] out
yeah it is not I mean at the end of the
day I think that she deserves love yeah
yeah does she have a condition or
something
she has a condition uh I mean she has to
yeah
right the condition is called
eight-year-old [__] syndrome
and they met they met I mean let's let's
see let's hear here let's see here what
he says
I was really inspired by her emotional
strength the way me and Shawna met was I
went to Thailand and I said here then he
every 38 year olds in this hotel where I
can get some action and then videos just
subtitles
yeah I mean like
it's sad because this is a girl who
deserves a companionship she's 23 years
old yeah the problem is you're
inherently suspect of the guy that wants
to take her out well you just can't like
kiss her in public I mean it's every
single restaurant is issued restaurant
yeah is this your daughter yeah you know
right imagine okay Nobu if you go to the
honeymoon suite with her the police will
be called they will call the police
so it's difficult yeah now she's 23. she
needs to find somebody that has her
condition sure
but they probably don't look good or
just like another an eight-year-old boy
or she needs to start dating an air nice
and horny but they can't dick her down
yeah she wants to get [__] down yeah
right and this guy is willing to Dick
her down when you start getting boners
like around like 30 like probably 12 or
something I don't know yeah
I imagine but still she wants a man
she's fully formed 23 year old in her
brain right right so she's looking for a
guy yeah and the problem is look go up
go up go up for a second look at this
look at this hold on he looks so young
oh who's that guy I don't know shawna's
blind date with a firefighter yeah let's
watch this they have like the same
condition I guess
[Laughter]
um what like I met Mike just date other
kids can you imagine yeah you were
parrots yeah and coming home and saying
this is my girlfriend Shawna Ray yeah
look
stop this for a second what the [__] is
TLC do it yeah yeah can we arrest the
people that work at TLC can we arrest
the executives that work at TLC she's
like some people think I'm eight but you
know this mouth ain't eight years old
this mouth does things
oh I only have 47 year old the woman
knows how to do it
don't worry about me my mouth knows
exactly what to do
I know
it let's get you in my [__] let's watch
this
right but what this isn't even like came
around the corner I was like oh he's
taller I was like oh he's taller that
there's already a foot difference I was
like we'll see how the similarities are
there people who watches are so are just
sick you know my wife my wife said I
mean my wife likes to send me Instagram
reels she sent me one the other day it
was like it started off it goes this
child's eyes were glued shut women like
to watch like we watch like beheading
videos right you know and people
[__] or whatever but the stuff that
women watch is actually way more sick
it's sick you know they want it well
disability kids disabled kids well the
thing there's shows on Tick Tock that
show the most deformed people that are
all in like relationships yeah and it
really makes you feel sad if you're not
in a relationship because you see people
who are like truly like it'll just be a
head with feet and they'll be like this
person is in a relationship you'll be
some guy in India who's like a snake
yeah it's the body of a snake and his
wife's a mongoose yeah and then they go
and this is his wife and she's like a
normal looking person
oh yeah this is great
Sean now it doesn't help that her
bedroom is decorated like a like an
eight-year-old yeah
[Music]
[__] for a bit and he's actually
visited once what are you supposed to
feel watching this what is the audience
what is like what do they want you to
like get out of this
you know I mean how do we know she's not
an eight-year-old
by the way
yeah yeah
the whole thing about her that's b23
that was a lie that's the season finale
they're like we're kidding around yeah
you are a Battleground
TLC Dan remember how Shawna always
needed lube and she would she would cry
after you came inside of her she would
just yeah that's because she was a kid
here at TLC Nathan for you it's a new
nation for you
let's watch a little bit more of this
this is this long and this is also be
the first time he's meeting my mom so
how often do you guys talk
others every day but then why are the
parents like vetting him like he like
they're like a Muslim family
you know what it is the parents know
that whoever walks through that door is
a problem is a problem they know uh
whoever walks through that door is a a
normal male is not dating her yeah sorry
yeah Shauna yeah a normal male right who
doesn't have any problems right is not
going to date a girl who appears to be
eight oh so you guys are going to
Chili's tonight can I just see your
browsing history really cool yeah yeah
could uh yeah okay tell us about your
last relationship yeah last relationship
dip I'm not really irritated by my
family when they bring up those future
questions I haven't talked about it with
Dan I'm kind of letting it go as it may
but it's nice to kind of try to see if
you can answer it
why do we have to label anything so it's
a question mark Or Now what are you
gonna do in 30 years when she looks like
she's 12. yeah I just don't understand
number one is this girl gonna live yeah
right that's a question right sure that
is how long is she gonna live
like I don't know she has some type of
condition and it may be fatal
um that's kind of weird they're making
sushi
okay that's kind of a red flag odd just
go get it just go get it
just go support the the Asian Community
why would you make sushi well you know
why he doesn't want the embarrassment of
sitting down at a table with her right
and having every Japanese person
yeah whatever you might get your head
cut off with a samurai yeah cause
they're really into honor over there
well they'll think it's the daughter and
they'll be like happy birthday yeah yeah
yeah
all right I mean let's just a little bit
more because this is fascinating it
happens okay I definitely think all
those questions scared Dan just a little
bit like I feel like he tensed up just
slightly when my mom walked in just cut
you think that at some point you might
settle down and kind of
base yourself in one place and then
travel when you other than honestly I
think traveling will always be a big
part of my life so I'll always be going
somewhere I really like going yeah I'm
out running the police yeah I just
really like places like Indonesia
Thailand you know Myanmar a lot
traveling because sometimes I get a
knock on a door
and he's a bunch of men and he wants to
see more computer so you know I like to
get around Afghanistan's really fun this
time yeah I got a friend who's a warlord
yeah he's got a beautiful house in Kabul
this is not is this her sister I think
so any questions I'm tired now
like they're just rapid firing questions
at you well I guess what
yeah I'm gonna ask another question what
would be the expectation if you and
Shauna and one daughter looks like she
said the other voter for Hillary Clinton
get along get along is something buds
yes something buds is the expectation
like
for her to travel with you or
um yeah one thing I'd love to give to
Shauna is the ability to see the world
in different cultures the planes are
tired and are very small and the hotel
rooms are very also very small and they
have rules in those countries about who
you can travel with you know they don't
really have the attitude like they do
here I don't get to kind of looks I'm
trying to take your daughter out for a
nice meal it's mostly business
taller and they treat people like human
beings they're not [__] nosy about
everything
I'd love to show us somewhere amazing
around the world
I think Dan would be a really good match
for Shawna because he's very smart
adventurous Shanna smart not very
adventurous I think that he could pull
her out of the comfort zone but still
make her feel safe
Jesus Christ
look at this lineup of freaks on TLC
what the [__] is are they conjoining are
they gonna bring out the Indian doctor
for my 600 pound life
my friend you want to [__] children this
is very bad my friend now actually I'll
she's 23. yeah nobody she looks like
she's at stop cut the [__] stop with
the [__]
laughs
but but I would love to just go into a
development meeting at TLC yeah would
there be anything off limit do that can
we do that while I'm I'll send my trip
yeah tell them that me and Tim yeah
it's like is there anything off limits
apparently not I don't think so is there
anything you can pitch these people that
would give them pause
I don't know let's find out I mean it's
like the creature people on the phone
I am Shauna Ray
this is the story of two Down syndrome
twins who are in love right no nothing
nothing makes these people stop yeah
there's not one thing that would make
them go uh I don't know yeah you know
they're conjoined twins yeah and one of
them's gotta go yeah TLC it's like the
craziest [__] thing I guess it's fun
to watch train wrecks like that I mean I
watch a lot of like Kitchen Nightmares
and that's fun watching people with
these horrible restaurants just run
their restaurants into the ground then
get yelled at
oh it's great that's fun but great brain
cancer left her with dwarfism that's
what it is yeah
she's got tattoos trying to look older
oh my God they just think it's a
temporary tattoo it doesn't help that
she's dressing like a kid too she should
go to Ann Taylor Loft to get some
sensible uh you know some sensible work
clothes I'm sorry
so you teaching your daughter how to
paddle board
something like that mate something like
that
it's more lover like one day he just has
enough and he just looks at the guy he's
like she's more lava
oh my God
[Music]
help us
have you heard they closed down Splash
Mountain no
this is a big thing Splash Mountain was
very a racist ride I think
because it's Song of the South Song of
the South yeah and you'd go through it
and it was like uh
it was like separate water fountains are
good yeah
it was like Briar Rabbit I now
apparently that's like the most racist
Disney movie like they won't yes because
all the Disney movies because I watch a
lot of Disney plus yeah all the Disney
movies go they give you warnings in the
front every single one it'll be like 101
Dalmatians they go we're sorry for the
racism in this movie right but they
don't play they don't Song of the South
it's been like wiped from the existence
they won't even let it anywhere anywhere
anywhere now when did that come out like
this 1970s look up songs myself because
I thought it was like the 50s or
something but I think it was I think it
I think it's just it's The Stereotype of
like a it doesn't Southern
it doesn't portray the black community
very well no I think it's just kind of
like outdated stereotypes
he's like Zippity Doo Dah Zippity it's a
great song though I really miss being a
slave I didn't have to say pretty dude
oh 1946 okay yeah
and the guys the CEOs his name is Bob
Iger that's two letters off from the
n-word yeah maybe they should think
about that that's a real problem yeah so
the Song of the South is see if you can
get something up from Song of the South
let's see how bad it is there's gotta be
it's got somebody yeah on YouTube has to
probably have a uh
now that's like the best ride at Disney
World though it was the best ride yeah
and you would go through this Song of
the South Village yeah and they would
play like uh zippity-doo-dah yeah and
then it was a large Flume a log flume
right that's all it was that's what it
was what will it be now just like an a
like
and is it gonna be like an explanation
of how the projects was built as you're
going through it yeah probably you'd be
like Robert Moses yeah like you'd be
sitting there and they'd be like Robert
Moses made the overpass to be the Alex
English ride yeah yeah Robert Moses made
it the overpass is too short for buses
to go out to Long Island bringing
African-Americans to their new homes in
the suburbs and you're like sitting
there like oh God this is
wonderful feelings
[Music]
I mean nothing wrong it doesn't seem
crazy like here's the thing I know it's
racist yeah but at first look no I bet
if you watch the whole movie I'm sure
it's horrible yeah I'm sure it's
horrible it's like a Charming guy
singing yeah and animation it must be
really bad for Disney to wipe it because
it must be horrible for Disney to wipe
in or it's a lot of pressure I'm sure
there's outdated stereotypes that are
very bad and they're kind of let's see
this maybe I don't know this seems a
little
he's like General Sherman was a war
criminal Eve the place where he was born
and raised
you mean leaving for good back up
oh no see that I don't brow patching
broke me nothing but trouble oh
and no trouble
this is where the trouble is and this
the place Oblongs away from don't you
know you can't run away from trouble
well I'm glad it ain't gonna be no
trouble there ain't no place that far
just the same I done made up my mind and
I ain't never coming back really
so long ago
sure hope you know what you was doing
don't worry about me I can take care of
myself imagine it's like 1946 you're
like on a date and you're she's like so
what do you do for a living and you're
like oh I'm an actor and she's like oh
yeah have you done anything I've seen
and you're like yeah I was in this movie
called Song of the South where I played
a an illiterate rabbit yeah there was a
movie that Disney did about the south
she's like really yeah I don't know you
know where can I see it well I don't
know the dark web where can you even get
you can't catch Song of the South yeah
so here we go why is it considered
racist this is good adults and children
alike will be able to appreciate the
magic of visiting a Walt Disney theme
park you get to meet
um uh you get to meet that kind of cast
of characters and enjoy thrilling rides
inspiring a sense of okay shut up
um the decision to replace the ride was
made in 2020 in response to its theme
Splash Mountain is based on a handful of
sequences in future
1946 Disney movie Song of the South
while some may remember okay come on
well some may remember seeing the film
you wouldn't find it on Disney plus well
the number of people urging Disney to
save Splash Mountain it's worth
contemplating why the closure of the
ride has been decided so why is the Song
of the South considered racist okay so
let's find this out here
Song of the South of consideration by
some adult audiences who argues it
offers a romanticized and fabricated
acceptance of life on a plantation from
the perspective of uh African-American
and post-civil War South
ultimately accusations of racism stem
from the portrayal of central character
Uncle Remus portrayed by James basket
he's presented as a Storyteller who
essentially offers the film's Gateway
into the Animated World of Briar Rabbit
which features in the Splash Mountain
ride although Uncle Remus is trying to
be happy with life on the plantation
this is exactly what a number of
audiences criticize okay so that's it
he's on a plane we didn't realize that
oh okay
um
yeah I mean we didn't realize that yeah
yeah okay
well that's not good
remember when they said that uh Sleeping
Beauty was rape culture because the guy
kissed her
that's something yeah Sleeping Beauty is
very boring
well the witch is good yeah Maleficent
yeah it's great yeah it's actually scary
the scene where Maleficent First shows
up uh Sleeping Beauty is actually you're
like oh God for kids like some of the
Disney movies when you look back were
like actually very dark yeah Pinocchio
is like is nuts yeah kids getting turned
to donkeys and thrown in an island yeah
some of the Disney [__] is weird to
slavery yeah something that's odd yeah
it's odd some of you watch it back and
you go
this is uh strange yeah
but a lot of those like fables like even
the Grimm's Fairy Tales back in the day
were very dark sometimes they were just
dark things where they were trying to
teach you a lesson
this kid's got to learn
so somebody tweeted shout out to the
very confused family from Chicago trying
to navigate Magic Kingdom asking
literally anyone and everyone what is
going on is it always like this
this is the last ride of Slash Mountain
so they had one more ride and now
they're going to rebuild the ride and
make it less racist they can't they just
but what are they going to do you can
still call it Splash Mountain and have a
that was I mean that was the best ride
at Disney World I think they may still
call it Splash Mountain but I think
they're going to the theme is going to
be different I don't know what the new
they're selling water from Splash
Mountain I mean people that are into
Disney are sick yeah yeah anyone who
buys water from the Splash Mountain ride
is sick yeah uh and I guess they're
they're changing the entire ride it's
gonna be LGBT themed probably Splash
Mountain The Flume is a dick that goes
right through someone's house
[__]
you can take pictures of yourself the
moment that you hit you go through the
ass what if Disney did that to just
paint you in a little penis boat and you
have to go through and then the whole
Rod is it took of the AIDS crisis and
then you just cut down The Flume and you
go right through an ass yeah
fun ride Ben Shapiro's like I went to
Disney World I had to go through an ass
I had no idea what was going on I sat in
the penis pout and I went through an ass
you know he's like a Disney guy really
he's like a Disney adult yeah yeah he
seems like it yeah he seems like a
little bit of a freak yeah yeah yeah
remember he said he'd never his wife's
[__] was never wet yeah because it's
not wet it's never been wet yeah yeah
like he he seems like a guy that would
get get a little too into Disney World
where you go like yeah
um
this is not great
[Music]
this is not great yeah I had some
friends where I grew up with where
they were really into it yeah my cousin
went on the Disney cruise for his
honeymoon yeah which I think is which
was strong not good yeah were you
[__] on the it's kind of a problem
you're supposed to [__] on your
honeymoon there's something about going
on a Disney cruise
if you don't have kids I gotta get it
with the kids yeah I told the guy that
but without kids yeah odd yeah I wonder
if they're gonna do a totally different
ride does it say anything like I wonder
if they're gonna destroy it and start
over or if they're gonna just yeah just
as a new theme new theme
what's the theme
like I wonder what the theme's gonna be
yeah what are the Disney movies are like
water related
do they do Avatar maybe it's Avatar
Disney it's Pixar yeah no it's no I
don't know what's in the Frog right
that's what it's gonna be yep oh oh New
Orleans all right that's fine okay
that's good yeah a bayou Adventure
they'll find a way to make that racist
yeah
all right look okay yeah I went a little
far with that yeah yeah guys how about
we not do and like just do something
futuristic yeah he's like stronger the
South's time he's like what are you
doing now we're going to the Bayou it's
narrated by Katt Williams yeah
to go into the buyer they're going to
call it like the Hurricane Katrina you
know they're going to do something where
people are going to go this is it's
gonna be it's going to be Paul Mooney's
Splash Mountain they're just gonna play
Paul Mooney clips
[Laughter]
Tiana's Bayou Adventure
is set to open late 2024 Disney World
and Disney World's Magic Kingdom the
company yeah I didn't see that movie did
you see that movie not at all yeah
I heard it was good
Tiana's Bayou Adventure did you watch
the new Velma on HBO The Mindy Kaling
show no did you see it Hunter my friends
did they said it sucked though yeah it's
bad it's like mentally ill why is it bad
it's just everything it's just sad yes
everything's bad
yeah but why why what's it's just like
it's just like about her it's just like
it's just like her story kind of but she
just just using the Scooby-Doo
characters
who cares about Selma yeah it's like
they they made a Lord of the Rings it's
all about Galadriel who's just like a
cold elf princess it's like she's not
supposed to be the [__] yeah nobody
watched that show huh nobody watch that
there's about Galadriel yeah that's not
it's not that's not the focal point but
they're like well women should be
centered then write another one don't
write another thing yeah yeah you have
to go back to an old world and grab a
female character that was in Central and
make it sent her a [__] origin story
didn't that thing cost a billion dollars
to make and it's just like
you know what are we doing long long ago
and you know we're old far far away you
know what show doesn't do that yeah
Tulsa King on Paramount plus you keep
plugging Tulsa you know what let's get
the trailer
I don't know I think it might be
[__] but it might not it might be
[__] I don't know if I'm a smart guy
or a dumb guy we're gonna you know
what's gonna tell us the trailer okay
let's watch this
you know it's just like like I I watch I
try to watch a little bit of everything
hold on
I don't know what you're expecting now
that you're back I'm respecting adequate
compensation
I want you to go there the horse races
springboard mile there's nobody doing
nothing you can do whatever you want
not exactly the welcome I was expecting
my name's Tyson welcome to Tulsa two
grand a week you drive from me now
what crew runs this neighborhood no crew
up in here we're in the middle of
nowhere
what would it be I assume you don't have
a key on there you assume correctly
Taylor Sheridan's good he's good he's
good I'll tell you what this is a show
he wrote Yellowstone he knows what he's
doing so even though this does look a
little dumb yeah I would watch this you
know exactly what's happening the whole
time that's right there's no like I
tried to watch Andor that Disney Plus
show okay you go like oh they're trying
to say something about like colonialism
and you know like and they're doing Star
Wars but they're trying to make it about
whatever and you go all right I guess I
can kind of follow this it's very dense
right you miss a lot of the show of
course this is like I know exactly
what's happening he [__] this lady and
then she goes uh and then she he tells
her that he's 75 and she leaves the
dollar yeah she's like he's a mob guy he
got out of jail he's going to Tulsa yeah
that's to be catch his mouth he gets his
mouth shut yeah he's being rewarded he's
going to Tulsa and it's it's a boomer
show but it's a very like self-aware
like he's very much like a loser in the
show he's very much a guy who like made
bad decisions right and he's trying to
fix his life yeah I mean listen I think
that's probably not the worst show out
there the best show okay I'm willing to
buy into that yeah I'm willing to
believe no if you need a show to watch I
mean yeah you would you would like it I
really liked it yeah yeah I'm waiting
for Euphoria to come back never saw it I
love it yeah I think it's great it's
just like hot teens they're not teens or
adults yeah they're playing they're
playing team and they're not all hot oh
no okay some of them are that's good but
then the rest of them are gross there's
like two hot ones there's some
jacobordians and diet and then maybe
there's a couple you know oh Sydney
Sweeney it's hot but yeah if they're all
on junk and they're all [__] up I mean
it's the American
but I thought they canceled Euphoria no
yeah HBO's biggest shot oh one of them I
thought they canceled it it's actually a
really good show like theirs like the
the father like comes out is gay he's
like he's like I suck [__] and like his
kids are there and his wife's standing
there and she's like go to bed he's like
I [__] a lot of guys like it's a very
it's a dark show yeah it's a dark show
but it's good yeah there's not much out
there right now that is good no
everything's kind of no it's good
Wednesday on Netflix it's silly and they
copied Harry Potter okay but it's
actually as a silly show goes yeah not
bad yeah if you if you're interested in
like why is it the biggest show yeah
they watch it the girl Jenna Ortega is
insanely good in it nice the Trump years
were bad for TV and they weren't good
you know because nobody knew what to say
nobody knew what to do yeah and
everybody was trying to you know make
things that are I think things are
irrelevant back now everyone had to use
their platform to like fight fascism
that's right you know that's when we got
some well we listen we had what are we
have we had Game of Thrones there were
some things during the time that was
Obama though because didn't it come out
in like 2011. yeah when did it end it
ended and it ended probably in like 20 I
don't know 2018 2019. yeah yeah I can't
I can't remember 19 I want to say it was
a few good things that came out during
the Trump years what I don't yeah in my
head I'm trying to I'm trying to
Euphoria is one of them
the movie I guess get out came out in
27. get out it was good
um
there was uncut gems uncut jams was
[__] amazing we saw Sandler at Nobu
today you didn't see him but I noticed
he was there yeah he was um
he was a
he's a resident yeah
one of the most awesome days of the
month is when our box of Awesome from
bespoke post arrive so we're just gonna
go ahead and unbox this thing right now
and tell you guys what we got
one of the coolest things in my bespoke
post is the lighter that is sent to me
and every month I am sent
what do they call this
a cradle for the coffee
that's in my bespoke post
um they send me a cactus
every month
and also this
and then this key
we don't know it's for but that's my box
of Awesome every month it's amazing it's
one of the coolest things every unique
item is hand curated from a small
business that you would never have heard
of otherwise
the great thing about bespoke posts is
when you give a gift to somebody they're
getting a new box every single month of
really cool stuff and it feels like
they're like oh my God I love this
person every month they remember how
good you were to them so go to box of
awesome.com and enter the code Tim
Dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome.com called Tim Dylan for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com
so
I'm excited about
I love a house of cards
new season
Spacey yeah Robin Wright right he's back
from the dead yeah No One's Gonna I mean
he already killed that guy
so no one's I don't think he's gonna be
a problem again nobody wants to get
murdered he had a few accusers he killed
two of them
right just let him back let him back
what's the problem yeah
he's not gonna you know No One's Gonna
Come forward now no you'd have to be an
idiot you'd have to be an idiot to
molest and to uh yeah uh blow the
whistle on it no you just have to just
you just you just you take it yeah well
you know no one wants to take risks in
Hollywood that's the problem with this
town
no one wants to you put a good because
that last season of House of Cards was
an abortion it was an aberration it was
horrible yeah but if you just say hey
we're doing it again yeah and
everybody's going back we're gonna be
okay what do you think of many Saints in
Newark I hated it I mean yeah nobody
liked it hated it yeah I hate it
terrible I hated it yeah but I hated the
Irishman too yeah I'm just over that
whole genre some people like the
Irishman like there I mean there's one
comic that said that thinks it's better
than good renan hershberg thinks it's
better than Goodfellas he's crazy that's
crazy but then but I tried to run things
that here's the thing when you have a
tank that no one thinks yeah it's bad
it's bad yeah this is the state it's not
you're not unique you're not yeah it's
not a contrarian take it's a bad tag
yeah when no one feels that way except
you yeah you're CR you're having a
moment that's crazy you should be
harassed online for that I mean what's
the what's his justification for that
I don't know it's an objectively bad
film bad the Irishman the Irishman yeah
I I want it took me like a week to watch
it to get through it I watched it and
then recently I was like maybe I should
re-watch the Irish mix maybe it is a
good movie because I had Matt Christman
on my old podcast and we talked about it
and he kind of like brought up some
points about why it was actually good
because it's about the end of the genre
or so like this genre is over the mob
movie's over okay well maybe if I looked
at it as that maybe if yeah then I could
reframe yeah but it's not there's
nothing fun about it or and I started
watching it and I was like I start and I
was like why not look at Song of the
South like that we go racism's over yeah
it's the end of race it's the end of
racism right this this ride is actually
the end of races yes they should they
should screen it at Metro graph actually
they should have dashed into a q a yeah
well I if I
outside
um
yeah I just couldn't get into the
Irishman I want Scorsese to like
challenge himself and make moves about
trans people and like and like drag
queens I want the next Scorsese movie to
be all Dre what about an all Drag Queen
Mafia movie let's call it Story Hour
story hour and it's just drag queens
with they're defending themselves
against the proud boys yeah
that's fun
or you could do Tulsa King it is a
little weird people are showing up with
guns to the story hour it is very weird
it feels like so it's a bit much it
feels a little excessive and I think
story hours a little is like story hours
yeah it's forced yeah so I don't think
anyone wants to read to kids it's boring
yeah you know yeah but obviously if you
have a kid it's important to read to
them but like nobody wants like nobody
like it's like oh it's Wednesday I gotta
unless you're like a lonely old woman
that's who should do store like Story
Hour like lonely old women who were like
I have nothing yeah I have nothing at
all and then they're like and every
Wednesday this old [__] looks forward
to going to read to these kids yeah but
covered wiped them out so you got to go
the next the next wrong on the ladder
which is
you show up with guns it seems like a
bit much yeah it is a bit much it seems
a bit much yeah but then you go like
well what about the you know like like
is it weird to take a kid to a drag show
or maybe not I don't know it depends it
depends yeah it's awesome you have a kid
I don't have a kid yeah so it I feel
like kids would see drag queens like
clowns yeah right yeah wouldn't they not
even understand like unless it's like
very sexualized show no but the reaction
to it yeah is much crazier yeah I mean I
don't know I I think I don't think drag
shows are appropriate for kids like if
they're at like drag bought you know but
if a kid sees a drag queen do it like at
a brunch or something yeah wouldn't they
just be like oh it's a clown yeah like
because drag queen kind of look like
clowns yeah you know yeah I don't know
that seems to be yeah
what I would think
but people get very
it's a cultural Battleground yeah I
don't I don't know I'm not as familiar
with it why do we still have libraries
yeah I don't know why is there even a
place to do this why do we have like
it's a good question why are there
libraries yeah it's just a waste of
money it's a waste of money could be
going to war it's a waste of money it
should be to go for the Ukraine yeah
yeah we could yeah nobody goes to
library Ukraine or Israel Israel
deserves more close the libraries and
send the money to Israel
how much money do they need to beat the
Palestinians Palestinians have no weapon
they have like nothing yeah but they
have the Rockets they have God on their
side they have the Rockets yeah and
Allah on their sides wow do you think
that's the way do you think that's the
way Israel presented to the United
States they're like listen yeah I know
that the United States like how much
people I know they live in mud yeah but
they do have the power of yeah yeah they
have God on their side and in the United
States like that's a good point here's
another three billion look you have to
remember we are evil and no one likes us
because we shoot children and
journalists in the head dude Barry
White's the best thing ever she was on
my podcast I'm like I'm like I'm like
um I'm like yeah but you shell schools
with the kids in them she's like we also
have to show hospitals I'm like that's
that's your defense I was like that's
the defense she's like yeah because
that's where Hamas like [__] they use
Shields of children I'm like that oh
that's an odd defense she's kind of a
ding dong huh well she's very into that
Nation yeah she's smart very smart yeah
but she doesn't think people who are
into Israel they really like it she's
smart and she's clearly smart but she's
really relentlessly pro-israel like if
Ireland did half the things Israel did
I'd go oh [__] that like I'm not as deep
in sure
but then you can make the argument if
there if the children are then they're
the children are not human Shields if
you're blowing them up right right
that's a good point yeah I I heard I
heard it on Chapel yeah she's in she's
in uh she's into it
she's into Israel that's her beat you
know yeah and she came on and she she
made some arguments I had Abby Morton
onto it Abby on and then and then people
yelled at me so I Barry on and then
people yelled at me and then I should I
should have had nobody on right because
what did we solve here yeah it's the
whole thing you have these people on
yeah one side goes nuts yeah and you
have the other person on the other side
goes and I'm like oh I'm an Irish guy
from Long Island why am I inserting
myself into this but look at the power
dynamics centuries long Feud yeah
no it's not centuries long it's like
decades long well
I think people want you to believe that
the conflict is like complicated yeah so
that you like stay out of it and you're
anti-semitic if you say anything about
it you know I I I you know am not that
educated about it otherwise all that I
all that I've always thought about it is
that it seems weird that you keep
building settlements yeah and you keep
pushing the borders opposing yeah and
that and that seems very antagonistic
yeah
that but I don't you know and they shot
that journalist in the head yeah yeah
yeah
I don't know you know but the beef seems
to go back like you see that Abby Martin
put out that documentary and she's
interviewing people in Israel and
they're like she's like so how do you
think we solve the problem and they're
like uh you know it's very difficult uh
but um I saw that maybe what you have to
do is kill them all yeah she came on my
show we talked about it really actually
made yeah Gaza fights for free she's
cool what's she like in real life
cool yeah she's cool cool you know yeah
a laid back but at the end of the day
what are you going to do about it what
am I doing what are you going to do what
am I going to do about that you know
what I mean are they buying tickets yeah
right Palestinians really buying tickets
you know what I mean like let's let's
cut to change it's like you know I mean
listen I don't want anything to happen
to them but I have no control over what
Israel does no so it's like we could all
talk and all these podcasts can talk
endlessly about everything no one cares
yeah so just make your money watch that
eight-year-old again yeah no but that's
better entertainment you know it's like
that doesn't TLC realizes TLC gets it
they get it a little bit they go yeah
you know what here's the reality we're
just gonna put a girl on who looks eight
and see who will [__] her huh that's the
reality imagine the TLC show called
understanding the Middle East right
right let's not do a number sometimes
you got to just shut your brains no I
wonder what the percentage of people who
watch these shows that have like phds
and stuff you know interesting yeah they
want to shut their brains off and just
watch something hey it's somebody who
sticks watch a couple with Down Syndrome
who [__] the [__] out of each other
yeah I mean there's something nice about
that somebody goes Shawna Ray I just
love watching this show Sean is such a
beautiful sweet young lady and seeing
how she handles the struggle she has in
life is really inspiring I understand
this is great it's half five star
reviews and half one star reviews yeah
yeah some people love it you would go to
a restaurant that had reviews like that
yeah some people really like it yeah my
wife and I have fallen in love with his
family
okay the next one I was expecting more
from TLC we all know reality TV is based
on editing and setting up particular
scenarios to keep viewers coming back
but this show literally places this
young lady in this situation every
episode where her age is put into
question being in a bar amusement park
ride tattoo parlor sex shop it's so
cornball you can almost see it coming a
mile away they put her in a sex shop
today we're going to
we're gonna find me a uh a dildo I'm
getting a dildo today at a sex shop I'm
really excited
I'm really excited to go to the pleasure
Chest to get a dildo try to find that
episode of the sex shop
I love how we see we did a five minute
uh Israel recap
guys immediately you don't want to hear
the Israel Palestine stuff but you
immediately start circling the the drain
with that where you go yeah I don't yeah
it is unfair that the Palestinians live
like that you know yeah it is yeah Mike
and Tim get real about Israel
I don't think they should live like that
and maybe they would yeah it's funny
because but the people people that you
meet like P like that you meet in the
world who are like into Israel are
really into it they're almost like
Disney adults where you go oh you okay
you really like this thing you know like
you know how like Sam Morel he loves the
Knicks yes you know you go like well I
don't want to like take that away of
course you love this thing so much a lot
of Jewish people I know don't even care
though yeah but then some people care
the most some people care the most yeah
well that's because that's where they
Got Fingered right there that's right
fingered yeah so now this is mind your
business now is she from Long Island
yeah so that I know that sex shop
Expressions I've passed it a million
times it's on I think it's off Sunrise
Highway let's watch this scene go back
to the beginning let's see this Shauna
is in a sex shop when she tells the word
hey sweetheart where's your mom
she's
what about the kid working there he's
like 15.
it's gonna be
over in that direction Eric got his
first job yeah he's smitten
the boobs are stupid everything is too
big it's not just the boobs can I wear
my combat boots no
so sorry while she's been planning the
wedding we've been planning the
bachelorette party so this afternoon
we're going shopping for some supplies
what do you think would make her the
most uncomfortable I am getting married
to my fiance Jessie originally Jesse
smallett so I thought Pittsburgh is the
perfect place to celebrate me getting
married and I still have friends there
and a ringtone
you have to hold it
no you put in between your legs yeah you
have to hold it with your legs that's
weird to grab the banana one yeah
I'm extremely nervous that Riley and
Shauna are gonna surprise me with some
raunchy stuff at this bachelorette party
I do not want it to be gross I don't
want it to be raunchy why don't we grab
a pack of peach confetti
watch and make this crazy sure that's
more annoying hello can I see some ID
hahaha
do I need to take it out for you or do
you like you need to scan it no
I'm 40.
okay
gotcha my first thought was
um is that a kid I was a little shocked
at first but um you know I was are those
hickeys all over his necks once I found
out that she was an adult both of them
were
apparently some other customers in the
store had the employee there come up to
us and ask for our IDs when people want
to verify my Qatar should buy this
network
okay things are going to be a little
different
at the DLC Network they have to
it's just funny it's like you know all
these people on the right wing like
America is just saying it's a moral
collapse it's degeneracy it's everything
and you're like oh there's a little
extreme and then you're like
it's like well yeah I mean maybe they
have a little bit of a point but what
antifa's not watching this show yeah who
is watching this show
or nosiness I'm not looking at you and
looking at what sex toys you're buying
and making sure
the [__] out of here
one penis pinata please
for me 23 year old Shawna
going for playing with I'm going to make
her uncomfortable
okay let me grab it but she doesn't even
act like a 23. no dude she's not 23.
now but it is now Tara is definitely the
most different between the three of us
yeah she's the most conservative
shawna's the one that pushes like the
raunchy gamble she's probably got a
stage bomb and she's like yeah so this
is my uh daughter and she's uh 23
because she had a brain cancer
yeah that's what we're going with can
you give us a reality show hey we'd like
a reality show my daughter will date
adult men
okay we can't call the show my
eight-year-old daughter dates adult men
so we're gonna have to lie so she's
listen ah we're thinking about uh doing
something here where my daughter she's
uh 23 but she looks like that's the
pitch in the TLC room to go yeah she's
23 but she looked eight everyone at the
DLC all the executives go oh and he go
it's hard for her to find love well of
course and they go yes we're just gonna
do a show where she gets kicked out of
bars and sex shops
it'll humiliate her and then we'll
attract maybe probably pedophiles to
come have sex with her we'll put it on
television we'll put it on TV
what's the problemo
yes in like public or like with our
family like our parents it's like she
has something to prove like she is an
adult and she is able to talk about this
stuff
anything else I think we're good are you
sure
I'm driving so
come on you can put that on the camera
shots
no I really can't apply them we ended up
getting some party games we got confetti
vibrator she's gonna kill us she's gonna
kill us it's gonna be worth it
she looks young too
I hope Tara's reaction will be good it
depends on the mood tears in of course
though if Terry is not in a good mood
when we give her the gifts what are you
doing please stop please do not make the
show anymore your people are bad you
people are not going to go to heaven you
understand that yes
they didn't bring the Indian doctor
you're 23 let me see your [__]
we're done let me I want to touch your
[__] I will tell you if she's 23 for it
I must do it inspection
[Laughter]
or not
that doctor's great he's so over all the
[__] he's so tired of being lied to
by 600 pound people no I'm actually down
I know I'm actually only 550. no you're
not
stop lying to my face don't [__] with me
anymore don't [__] with me anymore all
you do is eat do you think I'm [__]
get him up get this in your doctor do
you think I'm [__] [__] man
you think I'm [__] stupid man I want
you to stop with the [__] I know all
you do eat all day you see to eat this
is an eight-year-old [__]
your eight-year-old [__]
this is great after a bad way and the
League
this is great this is awesome how y'all
doing
driving this guy's amazing huh wait no
is that why you missed your last
appointment
you just have your bypass about two
months ago and when you left the
hospital you were down to 546 so you
lost only that's your God outside the
Oscar Meyer weenie Mo beard that's what
you drive almost 50 pounds at the same
time and she hasn't even had her bypass
yet
[Music]
things did watching people live
go back I wanna watch Amazing
it's I want to hear what she said
because like this is amazing hold on
knee has lost almost 50 pounds at the
same time and she hasn't even had her
bypass yet what in the world is going on
with you
you think it's funny
you have a gastric bypass I had a
gastric bypass just lose weight to lose
weight and you're not losing weight I
don't eat a third one
okay then we're not talking about
questions and I don't understand no more
and you understand what are you talking
about you're choosing to overeat and you
think it's okay no I don't think
I'm sorry my ride's here
now listen if you die they're going to
do a show it's an eight-year-old girl
who is really 23 is that what you want
is that what you want you want an
eight-year-old who's 23 go back
she got my dildos they're going to feel
what's on the line everyone at TLC no
one go to heaven
they all go to hell because we this is
this is the most moral show that is
earned to TLC
show that I can sleep a little bit
if you die they're going to bring in a
girl to get dildo she's a child a child
they're going to buy yeah that that show
is actually the uh it's the only one
it's the Ghost of Christmas future yeah
evil of TLC's beyond beyond human
comprehension yeah
okay let's watch a little bit more of
this this guy's amazing I guess I'm not
eating the right things I mean we gave
you the instruction that you need to
follow and you never follow it you play
your cards right until you got this
let's not feel bad for these people
playing this kind of game anything
that's okay
I'm towards somebody I'm playing any
game I throw up come constantly I eat
what I can keep down I have a Mexican
man in my office he says somebody steal
my hot dog cart he said he looking for
it that's how he feed his family and
he's and I think it I think you stole it
because you'll come in here with hot dog
carts I say what is that and you said
it's my wheelchair it's not a wheelchair
that is that man's livelihood that you
have with you with you
you don't understand
next week I inspect an eight-year-old
girl [__]
because
you die because you eat too much [__]
no I'm constantly because the surgery
forces you to when you overeat now I
think my problem is is I'm holding a lot
of fluid I can't hardly pee really I I
don't know I don't know what that man so
you take all his cotton candy that's how
he feed his eight kids and you'll just
steal his cotton candy you are a [__]
evil
foreign
[Laughter]
cup you're just drinking canola oil and
why you lie to me yeah
what do you mean you don't know
I don't understand either do you look
like you're a malnourished
and whatever you're overeating you're
torn up
it means the surgery is working to hold
you back when you make bad choices and
it's the only reason can you believe
this 100 pounds I don't have to listen
to this
do you not want me to eat at all you
know that's not what I'm saying at all
not being given a tool to help you
change your life now that you had the
surgery the physical drive to eat is
gone so you have to deal with what is
driving you to eat and that's the hard
part and you don't want to do it and
you're running from it and
self-destructing I'm done with this
conversation
no no we're gonna we're gonna finish
with you I might just waddle out of here
right now
the door
[Music]
okay all right this is completely
unacceptable
this man should be on every single
reality TV show yeah every single one
should be on To Catch a Predator yeah
and what happened when you say I want to
suck your 14 year old [__] you thought
that was okay he is the Real Housewives
what's his name doctor what doctor
Lee
that was
oh it says a doctor for my 600 friends
we should make an origin story about him
you should write a movie it's his origin
story I love him like like um
like uh like he goes to the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills he's like
you are all rich [__] you don't sit and
argue about dinner parties people in my
country I drink batteries and die you
stupid [__] you eating Malibu you argue
with this other [__] he's on kitchen
nightmare so why you would call this the
taco pizza it's not Taco it's not a
pizza
you keep doing heroin it's no good
intervention with that
the computer duster is not for your your
brain it's bad for your brain you know
that
this is where he loses it with a patient
coming here
here people's working for you amazing in
amazing
I don't have to listen to you I don't
have to listen
you piece of [__]
uh so it's this is so great I have an
Elementary School gym teacher he said
someone steal my parachute it does that
are you wearing the parachute is does
your clothing like they have to explain
to him that the next the next show
they're doing is about a child bride and
he's just sitting there he goes I have
dealt with fat people I've dealt with
Down Syndrome people this is now too
much you said to me we give you more
money but I want to go to heaven
laughs
now don't you give me not to drive don't
give me no child
I don't know what you told your homies
but you're not going to lie to me
okay sister girl
I don't know what red man and Method Man
say to you about your weight but you are
too fat
you look like Patrice O'Neil
she's not even that overweight what's
happening at all my 600
. I'm doing much better well I'm glad to
hear back and you're down to 306 pounds
yes sir
what you were doing well and staying on
track okay they replaced Simon Cowell
with him on American Idol he dropped to
losing only 16 pounds a month and now
you're done Tim I got a reality show we
get this guy to judge like an open mic
you're not funny at all I don't care
that you're gay yeah it does not matter
to me all you people get in here you
move to Brooklyn you come on the stage
you see I'm gay I'm okay you're bisexual
or you are bisexual bisexual
[Laughter]
right now
um
micro sin anything to promote I guess
it's too much fun yeah I know I should
move back we should put this out on
YouTube this is a great episode and we
should just put it out on YouTube and
see what happens I mean maybe we got
just that segment people aren't getting
no we're gonna put the whole hour out
okay great the whole thing out on
YouTube you know what amazing people get
angry and that's fine who would get
angry I don't I'm sure I'm [__] fat
[__] that hate your own 800 pound [__]
who's gonna be dead in a couple days
come on who cares micro scene comedy
baby I got a podcast called out for
smokes it's a lot of fun I do it with uh
Sean McCarthy and Scott Chaplin I got
some Road dates Baltimore Boston Denver
Cleveland and I'm taping a special in
New York City at the end of February
[__] yeah February 26th at the stand I
would love to get some people out
[__] at the show for that 100 yeah
um
I'm bringing a gun follow me on
Instagram if you can at Mike Racine
comedy all my dates are in Twitter
uh yeah at Mike Racine on Twitter okay
but yeah Instagram's where later this
week I'm bringing a gun to the Beverly
Wilshire Hotel to try to get something
going over there uh no uh
timberlakecomedy.com for all the live
shows
um I'm not gonna go through them all we
we get it go to timbillacomedy.com and
go to a bunch of play we just put Palm
Beach up and it's always fun over there
a lot of reasonable people uh
it's just reasonable reasonable people
hi Christine one of my oldest friends of
Comedy thank you for coming on thank you
beautiful wife and kid thanks buddy and
thank this guy thank you all right thank
you goodbye